Now it's your turn to write the code to
query for all conferences. You're going to need to add
the query conferences method, in the conference API class. You're
going to need to identify the function as an endpoint
method that uses HTTP post. And, now, if you
can't remember how to do that, just look at some
of the other functions in the file. An implement queryConferences
to return all conferences sorted by name. And when you've
written your function, go ahead and test it on
localhost. And that is important. It's really important that
you test it on localhost first. Don't cheat. Don't
deploy direct to appspot. You'll find, if you do
that, it probably won't work. After you run it
on localhost, go ahead and try out the query,
you can either do that in the API Explorer,
or you can go to the show conferences page.
Doesn't matter which way you do it, but make sure
that you run it on localhost first. And then, after you
test it on the localhost, I do want you to
deploy it to appspot. Now we're going to check that your application
actually works, and that it does create conferences and queries
conferences. I want you to go ahead and create a conference
called Udacity that's going to take place in London. It's important
that you get these right, that the name is actually Udacity,
spelled right, and that the city is in London.
Otherwise, our testing script might not work. And then go
ahead and enter your app ID here. This needs to
be the app ID, the app that's running on appspot.